the jurogan experience
are you going to wing it or do you want
to do the bridge a little bit and then
we can do it
yeah so from the
okay and we're back ladies and gentlemen
really
yes no rehearsal all right do you want
to rehearse no you're about to like
you can rehearse who you want no i don't
know what do you what do you think
so i think i think i got it we go into
your shred fest and then we have the
you know kind of break down then yeah
i'll just say this
i didn't mess it up last night
i i did
i was here my guys who decided to back
you up
it wasn't me oh i'm not first of all
you're amazing that was fun and it all
went
it went how it was supposed to go when
how it went and that's all it does yeah
it always goes how it goes
all right you wanna do this yeah
[Music]
rage on the wind tonight
[Music]
but i see them creeping on a sneak
attack
trying to smoke me out trying to make me
mad
and i won't
[Music]
fall for that
say like you mean it son
make me believe i'm the only one
when you press yourself right up against
my back
[Music]
i will
fall
stomping your boots making us quake
making our heads
with your bad news raining
down all day
[Music]
so
[Music]
do
[Music]
i don't want to hear
you yelling trying to bring me to my
knees with that coal you're selling
[Music]
let you hold my help just out of my
grass
living in your health
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right yeah you're rocking that 12
string you know i
feel like i should have gone for the
i should i like pumped it up on the
acoustic but you crushed it
you know i'm here to support i do what i
can
that was so good do always fun rocking
with you oh my god likewise
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre
on your spotify app go to spotify now
to get this full episode of the joe
rogan experience